genuinely tastes like somebody's already
tener Dada
so we've got cat food it seemed like
that to me just says that to Bob smell
it like PC it's like something out of
1972 let's have a look oh two bits of
accessories
oh well that doesn't bode well on an
overnight somebody's put some chickpeas
for some to chill down and they just
yeah it might need this oh now I have
had fermented soybeans
and they are quite nice wait why have
you just put in there I think I've put a
little bit of wasabi so I've had them
before you should go first yeah I know
you have your mine it's like somebody's
already eaten good will feel like heaven
when you've tasted that don't be mixing
the soy beans
for me that wins
please pudding I mean there's nothing
natural there that smells like a 12-yard
bedroom when they first buy like the
odor and they just spray it everywhere
it's just like the most sickening Pocari
sweat it's just do it I started the
sport drink so it's nice you're just
kind of loped femto is the devil's juice
but you never know my kids don't
advertise it sir pintu always good
always refreshing always been this I've
got no idea what what this actually is
Joe this just reminds me of being a pro
athlete I thought drinking those drinks
that you don't want to drink and now I
get to join me this makes me think I'm a
pro at all
Cheers this is the best whoa no no what
I'm deciding I think you're gonna go
this because you don't even know what
these are giving me the chance
no but I can tell you that you are
missing out because these are amazing
Gabby you know I trusted who looks like
the inside of a plant smells quite nice
mm-hmm is this like the phrase see
weighted thing nowadays Doug I need to
put that what is the point in that
so what kind of friend goes oh do you
want one yeah just take one serious well
we know what's this
yes all about okay wait you malteaser
challenge we can that's pretend well
what's his star is born they're gonna
get together on this movie all day every
day
ah frazzles oh please look like ginseng
oh I wasn't expecting that
oh you're gonna bug a crisp dry and you
are beat Scott what's happening yeah
what kind of snack is that my tongues
burning a frazzle it's only one winner
for me rotten
absolutely okay
is this an audition for my celebrity
[Music]